hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm and i love going over
old iconic games from some of the
world's greatest chess players and this
game comes from the 1934 zurich
tournament every year there's gonna be
important tournaments that chess players
care about in the 1930s desert
tournament was one of the largest most
important tournaments they could play
and it had all the top chess players and
it was an international tournament which
they didn't have as many international
tournaments as they do these days and
this is the most iconic game from that
tournament our two players whites gonna
be played by max ube at this point he is
33 years old this is right before he
became the world champion so he's one of
the younger players in the tournament
but also doesn't have the notoriety that
his opponent has he doesn't have a world
championship yet his opponent he's been
a world champion for 27 years that's a
manual Alaska at this point he's 65 so
he's towards the end of his both
professional career as well as his life
but he is no stranger to the highest
level of chess played and he wants to
make sure that this new kid on the block
who has been doing extremely well max
who bet knows that he is still one of
the greatest chess players of all time
although he is no longer the world
champion so we'll go ahead and get into
it with max starting out and he plays d4
and then d5 we'll get into the Queen's
Gambit line with a c4 and then the
Queens gambit declined with East six
just the normal main line here Knight c3
Knight f6 Bishop here to a g5 and then
after Knight to d7 this is the Cambridge
Springs defense and then we have III now
common from here would be c6 Knight f3
and then Queen to a5 but Emmanuel Lasker
decides to change things up a little bit
and play Bishop to e7 instead max
continues with Queen to c2 and then
castle on the Kings side in a three now
you don't always see the pawn coming up
here to a3 if you are going to play your
pawn up on the wings here h3 is pretty
common but that's usually to stop the
Bishop coming down here the g5 that is
not going to be happening anytime soon
with the
set up from Alaska here but instead you
may see pond take on d5 you could see
Bishop here to d3 this is threatening
this pawn here on a tennis Peschel e
right after black castles on the King
side you could always take here on f6
then you're threatening here on h7 so
White has lots of different options he
decides to opt for a3 a little slower
move but it does protect this square
here on before from the bishop coming
down but usually not something that
blacks even looking to do he just played
his Bishop 87 if it comes down here it's
not even that bad if white recaptures
with his pawn here on c3 if there is an
exchange because you can always just
capture here on d5 there's no longer
gonna be double pawns here so a3 not the
move that I was expecting to see here
from max but that's what he plays and
then rook to e8 centralizing his rook
rook over here to see one says yeah I'm
expecting an exchange here at some point
max may even be looking to take here on
d5 himself here this does put the rook
on c1 for a semi-open file and that's
exactly what Lasker does he takes with
this pawn here and then Bishop
recaptures here on c4 which is always
what you want you want to recapture
material as well as develop so this is a
very active square for his Bishop can
also castle on the Kings side if he ever
needs to bring his bishop back here to
a2 one of Bobby Fischer's favorite
squares for his LightSquared Bishop he
can do that as well Knight to d5 great
little outpost here he can always
recapture with his pawns on different
options depending on how you know he
wants to move forward in the game but
first max is gonna take material here on
e7 take that Bishop there's gonna be the
exchange a knight here to e4 Knight
comes back to f6
I thought from here when I was analyzed
in the game that you would just see the
knight take here after the knight takes
you see castle on the Kings side seems
like a pretty good setup here instead we
see the knight come back here to g3 so
not being super aggressive is max
against Lasker here then we see pawn c5
we do see castle on the King side pawn
takes Knight recaptures here and the
knight too
be six attacking the bishop now once he
attacks it does come back here to a to
always like the bishop coming back here
day two just such an annoyance for black
to have to deal with it controls so much
of the center of the board
luckily for black he does have the pawn
here on a six o or a six so it does make
it a little bit easier for him to not
have to worry about the the bishop
eyeing down this long diagonal attacking
the King but still kind of annoying to
have to worry about this bishop here on
a two now if you look from blacks
perspective he really needs to get his
light square Bishop involved into the
game now his rook and queen are playing
somewhat defensive right now and that's
fine he can always counter-attack later
but for sure Bishop to d7 makes a lot of
sense here but instead we see rook to b8
which this does set up for the bishop to
get involved into the game this Bishop
is defending the pawn but the coin is
also defending the pond so yes he's
bringing it over here so his light
square Bishop can move and he doesn't
have to worry about the lights where
Bishop defending this but knowing that
the queen is here I think he could have
just played Bishop here to d7 but he was
the world champion for 27 years he can
kind of do whatever he wants to he
decides to play rook to b8 so we'll go
with that pawn to e4 just trying to push
in the center of the board here work
through the 8th just gonna get more
involved into the center of the board
came to e8 early on didn't have any
other options now that the board state
has developed a little bit more decides
he wants to get a very active rook here
and play rook to d8 rook to d1 just says
yeah if you want to try to attack that I
want to defend that a Bishop to d7 so
now does get the livescribe bishop
involved into the game pawn to e5
forcing the knight to move comes back
here to e8 so this is one of those times
where you look at the board state and
say if one side is going to retreat the
other side should be pretty aggressive
with their game plan
Bishop to b1 although it is coming back
on one square it is also attacking the
square here on 8 7 so we do see g6 kind
of the obvious move here blocking the
attack here coming from white standpoint
Queen 2e for always looking to
centralize material you want your most
important pieces to attack as many
squares as possible that's exactly what
Queen to e4 does does attack the
material here on a b7 since he played
his Bishop here to d7 he does have his
rook here on b8 defending that which is
kind of what he was looking for early on
Bishop comes down here to a4 I does have
his Queen here on e7 now the thinning
that as well as we talked about this is
attacking the rook here besides yeah
just go ahead and play pawn to b3
attacking the bishop bishop comes back
here to d7 pawn a4 so really just almost
bathing and max a little bit to push up
his pawns a little bit decides now to
bring his Knight down to d5 this is
another outpost here with the pawn
probably not gonna be exchanging
material here with his queen or ruck and
don't really see a very easy path for
his Bishop to get here as well so this
night here on d5 is pretty much gonna be
staying there for a while Bishop to d3
just centralizing a little bit more
since the pawn came to g6
there's not gonna be attacking on the
keen side so once to get the bishop
involved into the game rook to c8 Bishop
to c4 so definitely maneuvering a lot
trying to get rid of it the night here
on d5 Bishop to c6 says yeah if you want
to exchange that's fine we'll go ahead
and do that takes the knight here or
takes with his night here on c6 we do
think Ducey in exchange so we have an
isolated pawn here for black on the C
file something he's gonna have to worry
about defending for the rest of the game
unless he exchanges that off the board
rook here to a d3 Knight down here to a
B for attacking the rook rook swings
over here to f3 so both sides if you
kind of think about their strategies
here max is really looking to now attack
on the King side of the board he's
always had his Knight over here to g3
which early on we thought he may take
material here on f6 exchange Knights he
brought it back here to g3 it has not
done anything with that it's now time to
start getting involved in to the attack
here so
his work over here he cannot bring his
other work involved into the game he can
play h4 start to chip away on the
kingside the board if you look from
Lasker standpoint he now has two rooks
that are involved into the game White
has given up control of the D foul so he
can get his D file the rook involved
into the game and now he can start to
counter-attack with his own queen
doesn't need to get his knight involved
into the game it's not doing anything
right here on the e8 square so that's
really what both sides are gonna be
looking to do going forward
Lasker plays rook to c7 preparing to
bring his work over here to d7 double up
his rooks and really control this D file
pawn to h4 as we talked about rook to a
d7 and then h5 right here starting to
chip away on the King side the board
going down here to g5 says yeah okay you
got a lot of material over here I got to
get my queen involve try to stop some
sort of crazy attack that you're gonna
have here we're here to e1 and then rook
down to d4 attacking the Queen on e4 now
max looks at this and says I'm not even
worried about you taking my queen right
here I'm gonna go and take your pawn on
g6 now usually if you're playing a
top-level player they're not just gonna
give up their queen for no reason and so
that's the reason that you see the pawn
take back here on g6 because this is the
plant trap if you take with your rook
here on e4 then max is just going to
take with this pawn on f7 this is check
after the King moves then Knight takes
here on e4 this is threatening the Queen
the Queen pretty much has to move here
after the Queen moves then the pawn can
take here on eight this is going to this
could pretty much be any piece this
could be a queen attacking the King here
could be a knight attack in the queen I
went ahead and said yeah it could be a
knight but after the King takes then the
bishop takes here on e6 yes white no
longer has a queen but he has a lot of
material on the board the point this
King right here on EI tis completely
exposed white should have
a much better game going into the
in-game here so that's why while yes he
could take the Queen here on e4 decides
correctly yeah we're not gonna be doing
that cuz white can overwhelm me take
back with my paneer and there's still a
lot of protection in front of his king
how can white really attack this right
now he can't he's gonna have to chip
away a little bit more so after that's
defended correctly now white does need
to bring his Queen back here to e2
worked in the d2 always want to get your
rucks down to the second ring if you're
black just putting so much pressure on
your opponent's Queen comes back here to
f1 this is one of those situations where
you can feel it's shifting towards
Emmanuel a secure standpoint you never
want to have your Queen down here to f1
this is sort of I'm playing just
completely defense could have easily
just gone to Queen III and says yeah
you're putting a lot of pressure we can
exchange on the board the Queen comes
off that's completely fine yes you have
double pawns here on the e-file but
White's completely in a situation where
they can at least draw may not win in
this position but once you bring your
Queen back here to f1 now you just have
to hope for a draw because you're in
complete defense mode
Lasker continues the attack with Knight
to c2 and max it almost looks like he
found an out here and he plays Knight to
e4 one of the more iconic Forks that you
see in chess looking to attack both the
rook here and the Queen but Lasker saw
that he wasn't threatened by that at all
after he played Knight - C - because
Knight coming to e4 he just gonna
continue with his own game plan and that
is Queen to e5 now this does give up as
Queen but this is completely fun all
part of his strategy the reason he gives
up his Queen is Knight to f6 and this is
what was played in the game this is a
check and a discovered attack on the
Queen so pretty much Lasker needs to
take with his Queen Queen takes here
takes the Knights work comes up here to
f6 and the knight takes that rook
right here so he did get a pawn he got
that pawn here on e5 got a knight in a
brook and for him that was enough
material knowing he has so much material
attacking his opponent and his opponent
max doesn't have a lot of material
involved into the game and so all that
put together still has an attack on this
rook right here on one said that was a
good enough exchange for me to give up
my queen rook comes here to c1 and then
the Knights start to get involved into
the game and Emmanuel asked her if you
look at a lot of his games there's so
well with two knights it's just really
fun to watch how he maneuvers all over
the board just controls so much of the
board especially in the endgame and
that's exactly what he does here Bishop
comes down here to e2 just trying to
defend as much as possible here Knight
to d4 attacking the bishop bishop here
to f3 Knight comes down takes on f2
nothing really that white can do here
can't take away this King obviously it's
defended by the rook can't take with
this Queen it would fall to the rook
Queen comes up here to c4 continues the
attack Knight to d3 attacking the rook
where comes over here to f1 playing
defense Knight to e5 this is now forking
both the Queen and the bishop here on f3
Queen comes over here says yeah I'll go
ahead an exchange material here after
the pawn takes Knight down here - II -
attack in the camp you can see it's now
opening up for more attacking lines for
black that the King is completely
exposed here both the rook and the
knight are doing extremely well
attacking together and the rook can also
come down start to attack we haven't
even mentioned all the pawns they could
start pushing if you wanted to as well
King comes to h2 Knight up here to f4
this is a discovered attack now the rook
is attacking the King then we see the
King come down here to h1 rook to d4
attacking the Queen Queen comes up here
to e7 where else does the Queen really
go yes I don't like the move from the
Queen coming up here to e7 it's
completely alone that's not what this
game is about anymore why are you
bringing material up here but really
there
no good squares for white to come to
Lasker then comes to g7 just stopping
some of the squares that the Queen could
come to that might be annoying to him
coming back here to c7 attacking the
Knights but the Knights completely
defended both of the rooks are defended
the King over here on h1 not defended at
all you can start to see how this is not
gonna go well for white where comes down
here to d5 this also opens up the door
for the rook to come over here to h5
then we have rook e1
we're here to g5 could have also just
played his work over here to h5 as well
check in this case maybe queen or king
to g1 pawn down here 5 maybe the rook
captures the rook comes down here to d1
we could see the Knights get involved
into the action doesn't really matter
how it goes it's gonna in extremely well
for Lasker there's so much material
attacking the King here he could
eventually just bring his work over here
to e 1 he has both the Knights and the
rook attacking this rook here on e5 so a
lot of different options in the game
decided that's he was just gonna build
up a little bit more than stead of bring
his rook to h5 bring it to g5 just
stopping all the squares that y can go
to can't bring it to the G foul now and
is also attacking the square here on g2
with his knight so now all be asked to
do is attack on the H file and it should
be good game Queen takes on c6 no other
good options if you start to look at
where y can go here his queen in is rook
not connected at all so they're kind of
on their own just trying to attack
that's not gonna help
and then rook to d8 and this is where
max decided to go ahead and give up
because we're coming over here to h8 is
inevitable there's no way to really stop
it yes max could come in and try to save
face by playing Queen to c3 checking the
opponent it's just gonna delay the
inevitable he's going to end up losing
the Queen even if he brought his queen
down here to see to just block it over
here on h2 just going to delay the
inevitable
so this is one of those games where 20
moves ago we may have had someone
nowadays they would just resign because
they they went down a little bit and
they move on
that's why I really like some of these
older iconic games especially with some
of the top level players they
appreciated the art form
that was the endgame they let their
opponent do their thing and so we see
something like this go to the 50th move
and they played it out until now it's
you know it's it's pretty much over now
but we're back in the day we just would
not have ever seen a game like this so
hopefully guys enjoyed this video
Manuel asker don't get to see too many
of his games definitely plan on covering
more of him but yeah 27 years as the
world champion even at 65 years old in
this tournament showing he still has a
thing or two left in his tank against
max 33 years old you know no one even
knows he's gonna be the world champion
pretty soon here but I think you got a
little taste of what it takes to be at
the highest level
this probably propelled him in the near
future to become the world champion
thank you guys so much for watching this
video if there are other iconic games
that you want me to cover feel free to
let me know or if there's any other
chess openings strategies anything like
that let me know best way to get ahold
of me is through email the chess website
at gmail.com thanks again for watching
I'll see you guys in the next video